and I guarantee this is the best show
that Bravo has or will have on air ever
is gonna be this season of Shahs see me
if you don't think so
Mike it has been a minute since we've
seen the Shahs and a lot of ish has gone
down since we last saw the Shahs what
the hell happened to this friend group
man what happened we're blood
nothing can ever get between this barn
[Music]
tragic was the death of our friendship a
lot of great things have happened and a
lot of bad issues happened as well let's
get into some of that bad stuff Reza and
MJ falling out because I think for at
least the fans of the show that is a
blow mm-hmm that's a hard thing to
process as their friend what was it like
for you to process that well this is the
second time it's gone down and our
friendship and of years of friendship
like the economy relationships are
cyclical they go up they go down and you
know they just hit a rough patch and
this patch is really rough like Titanic
rough and as badly as I want to say I'm
hopeful that there'll be friends again I
just got to tune in and see exactly how
everything went down it's it's kind of a
blur to me even and I was there and I
experienced it I still was like what's
that happened yeah it can you tease it
all what pushes them to that breaking
point this time
MJ was going through a very hard
delivery for shams her baby and she was
not supposed to come back because she
didn't feel like this was what she
wanted to be a part of because she was
so focused on her baby and in the
meantime there was some rumors spreading
about Reza Adam their relationship a
four-game night and it was stripping MJ
wasn't there to kind of give her side of
the story
so everything was brewing and exploded
and by the time MJ felt good enough to
come back the issue turi hit the fan
okay you get it boiling boiling boiling
they're not in the same room I mean
they're getting that's a moment boiling
it was like Breaking Bad boom like
I've never seen Reza so furious in my
life wow he's a big dude and I'm a
pretty strong guy and I was trying to
hold them and I couldn't because he was
in so much rage and you're gonna see
what transpired to get him there okay
it's really crazy and everyone has to
watch to see I got goose bumps
[Music]
I want there to break his legs it does
seem as if almost everybody in this
group has some issue with Reza this
season including you the guy is just
he's very emotional he has a lot of
demons that he's been dealing with and
he likes like cutthroat yo are you with
me are you against me and it was like no
I can't be with you because I don't know
the full story yet I can't make a
judgement without understanding exactly
what's happened so it's black and white
and Reza's world completely okay there's
no grey we're in a bit of a gray area in
this first episode though because
destiny brings some information to the
table that Adam has maybe been
unfaithful to Reza I'm sure that leads
to a lot of the drama with Reza right as
soon as I heard I'm like you'll resonate
to talk to you and that's when things
just kind of went downhill okay so that
was that got the ball in motion for
everything we're going to see this
season because if I keep a secret that's
about somebody else I'm just as bad as
the person who started that rumor got it
we do see in the trailer though it does
look like at some point we're going to
get to a place where we can laugh about
the strip
it's not all drama it's not all
craziness at the end of the day there's
a lot of funniness a lot of craziness is
love and and and and babies and new
relationships it's it's all just a lot
of life happen a lot of life and I
guarantee this is the best show that
Bravo has or will have on air ever is
gonna be this season of Shahs I
guarantee you that's a big promise Mike
I'll take you up on it
hey I don't see me if you don't think so
kind of last question on the resident
seemed like all of you were fine at
Bravo con you were all there celebrating
the weekend looked happy smiling faces
where does the group stand today at the
end of day we're professionals right and
we we represent a huge company and an
amazing network like Bravo and we had to
put on our big-boy pants and big boy you
know clothes and and act as if as if
were professionals and put our
differences aside because we were there
for the fans
okay so game day faces maybe wasn't
representative of where things stand
with you guys gotta watch and see all
right exactly what I'm talking about
all right well let's talk about you yes
you're a man in love I found my soul
mate how did this happen
Paulina yes how did you two meet give me
kind of the CliffsNotes of how this
woman came into your life um a friend of
mine in Las Vegas had a friend that was
really good friends with Paulina and
knew that I was seeing all knew that she
was single and I liked she's Persian
she's Jewish she's really freaking cute
you gotta meet her I was like all right
you know I'm dying to have some fun and
we went on a date and I just looked at I
was like in my own mind I was like I'm
gonna marry one day I still feel that
way yes yeah she's the 100 times more
than I did the day I met her this is how
down she is I was like hey I want to
take you out let's grab sushi we were on
the way to go get sushi is like you know
what I'm really in the mood for like
watch like Taco Bell it's like Taco Bell
all right cheap day let's do it we
started talking about for three hours
come to find out she's vegan she didn't
want to tell you cuz she didn't want to
scare him
persian-jewish girl that's vegan like
I'm like okay so that means I'm never
gonna have some Persian food and we just
sat and talked and she told me
everything and her story the way her
looks her personality was just I fell in
love with her and if you have a deep
chat at Taco Bell pie in the right place
it was so deep that the security guard
this big dude comes up to his clothes
look like you really having a good time
like I guess we are how I didn't realize
they were a Taco Bell wasn't in that
moment that you knew she was your soul
mate loving a Taco Bell mic yeah it's
just the conversation the connection
that just just she just got me it was
cool I will never ever get married again
I'm gonna ask Mason I want to marry your
mommy is that okay you had previously
said you would never get married
together what change
I even to a Paulina I'm never getting
married again and she told me the same
thing she's like I'm never gonna be
married again especially to a Persian
guy we go damn okay well are you sure
you still wanna go on a date with me
like what are you doing let's go have
some fun you're cute you know and when
you meet the right one you just you just
you just know I'm falling more in love
with her every day that I'm with her
because I just realize more things about
it that are so lovable we've watched you
in and out of relationships over the
course yeah almost the last decade yep
we've seen you cheat yep how do you know
you're not gonna cheat again people
don't cheat unless they're in a
relationship they're not happy and me
and my ex-wife had a lot of issues and
the cheating happened before we were
married we were dealing with a lot of
fighting and we were barely talking let
alone intimate it was just we're
constantly at each other's throats and
that led me to look for love in another
relationship or you know another
situation and I'm not that person I was
anymore
I broke my own heart I broke my
ex-wife's heart I destroyed two families
that came together to be as one they
were separated so I would never do that
again because I don't ever want to feel
that guilt that I harbored for so long
that made me feel as ever gonna get
married again so you learned a lot from
that experience every day in the
premiere there are some flashback scenes
to Jessica right when was the last time
you guys spoke we don't really talk it
was the last time we we chatted was to
show me pictures of her of her beautiful
son
yeah that's growth - absolutely I'm so
happy for her she's a wonderful person I
was an okay person and we just weren't
right for each other speaking of kids
Pauline that's got kids right what is
Mike the stepdad like I never thought I
could love two babies that were my own
offspring as much as I love them like
when I come over to Pauline his house
they rush to see me Mikey Mikey Mikey
and it's just like regardless of how
hard of a day I had they gave me a life
they give me energy again and it's so
amazing to watch them grow up in the way
at six and four the way they communicate
am i dude I wish I was as smart as you
too when I was that age like the
six-year-old negotiates with me to get
chocolate and candy and sushi and I'm
like how do you know how to already
negotiate dude you're wild and he gets a
kick out of it he's like you know like
I'm like you were amazing it's like
scary you might be yes yes he kind of is
have you guys talked about expanding
that family having kids of your own
absolutely although I love these two
like they're my own I want one of them
or two or three of my own you know a lot
she's young and she makes me feel young
and we're gonna try let's see okay
what's the timeline for putting a ring
on the finger we haven't talked about
that yet I definitely want to do that
but right now I have so many massive
projects on my hands that I need to kind
of coddle those
and make sure that they are okay before
I take the next step and fully yeah
marriage it sounds like such a wonderful
you know idea and we've glamorized it
but if you're really in an amazing
relationship you don't need to have that
paper to make you feel like you're gonna
be with that person for the rest of your
life okay yeah all right just
complicates stuff
living in the moment yep getting some
business stuff out of the way yep then
we'll focus on that business yep got it
in the premier Reza does kind of joke
imply that you're with Paulina for the
money like a reverse gold-digging
situation I got plenty of money my
friend I don't need her believe me I'm
building a massive project in Hollywood
that will spit off a lot of money to me
and I have my CBD line that's just
kicking ass so the last thing I ever
look for in someone is what they can
bring to me other than their heart their
soul their mind their love their
attention I don't need anyone's money
thank God
so Reza unfortunately projects and that
might be his projection even though I
know Adam doesn't have much so why would
he think I'd be any different than him
that's on him okay yeah all right to
wrap things up here what are you most
excited about for the fans to experience
this season
except for my CBD line except for your
CBD line okay it's GG gotta be mad at
you someone's mad at me this is a
multi-billion dollar industry you know
when you have competition it makes you
become better it shouldn't make you feel
bad like hey let's both get after it
especially if you're all friend
something like shares in the mix - yeah
absolutely absolutely but most excited
about this season everything this will
be the best show on Bravo ever this
season is insane you've said that twice
now so I gotta believe I'm telling you
is there anything I mean a lot went down
so is there anything you're dreading
having to relive hi pulling his parents
he's gonna be on TV
yeah like Persian Jewish girl on
television without her parents knowing
is a
big deal her parents said no no don't
they know now well yeah they've seen the
previews so they're like when she when
you met her parents said they were they
aware that you were on TV yes they
weren't very excited about that
okay that's some stuff to work through
my dad I got my work cut out for me
that's why I rolled up my sleeves yeah
you're very professional today yes it's
the new me
all right one word to describe this
season
what's it about one word yeah
friendship friendship yep at the end of
day we can't lose sight of that I know
there's a lot of drama but this is a
show about friends and we all deeply
love each other at the end of the day
even though we have our ups and downs no
real friendship doesn't have ups and
downs because if it doesn't you're not
in a real friendship
[Music]